hey everybody you're watching
gamespot.com I am Alexa Ray Korea and I
am here with Kevin van or hi and we're
uh here to talk about something very
near and dear to Kevin's heart and that
is Assassin's Creed as you all know the
new game is being revealed today in like
5 minutes Uh Kevin I actually saw the
game last week so I know it's coming but
I want to ask you you I don't know [__]
for you've been with this series forever
you love it you've got a tattoo I do I
do show your tattoo oh you got the sweet
tattoo wait wait wait there we go sweet
tattoo um what elements of previous
Assassin's Creeds what things about the
roots of the series do you really want
to see come back like what do you love
about the
series well I mean the biggest thing I
love is the free running is the is the
is the uh the feeling of soaring across
the city without anything helping you
soar like the idea that I'm parkouring
and I'm I'm almost kind of an acrobat
and I don't need a parachute I don't
need any any kind of fancy machinery to
get around I can just run free wherever
I want to my favorite part of the series
I mean I still think that Assassin's
Creed 2 is the Pinnacle of the series
and and I think that uh one thing that I
would like to see I guess from from
Assassin's Creed going forward well a
couple things actually one is I'd sort
of like to I'd sort of like the uh
kisss uh design philosophy which is keep
it simple stupid um I've never heard
that before I think I think that assass
the original assassin's was was you know
criticized for not having enough to it
so I feel like Assassin's Creed to hit
that exact perfect ratio of having stuff
to do without making it feel like it was
just overloaded with stuff for the sake
of stuff and I feel like Assassin's
Creeds have become frankly overloaded
with stuff for the sake of stuff and uh
what I'd really like to see is is a sort
of a a return to you know every mechanic
having a meaning um and that's that's
probably what what I would want and and
of course a a lead character that can
carry not just one game but multiple
games after which Etso still the best
leading man in Assassin's Creed maybe a
leading woman would be nice a leading
woman would be nice I me we've had
leading women um but they they've been
sort of relegated to the sidelines we
we've had uh you know Assassin's Creed
Liberty was it Liberation Liberation
thank you I mean I I
know and then of course the the most
recent Assassin's Creed Chronicles China
um had Shia Jun and and uh but they but
you know it would be nice to see a
leading lady um but uh yeah um but but
really you know for me it comes down to
that like let's let's strip away all the
excess stop putting stuff in for the
sake of stuff make it make make it
meaningful yeah so we've actually uh we
have they've already announced or we've
seen leaks that it looks like it's going
to be set in Victorian London what do
you think about what do you think about
bringing Assassin's Creed modern how do
you feel about sort of a modern era
assassin it's been leaning to that right
I mean we've we've been slowly working
our way up in the main stories and and
okay so look I'll be honest like I'm one
of the people that actually kind of
liked the Desmond thing I know that
makes me a weird freak it wasn't bad it
was it had it I think his story was
stronger in the beginning I think it
sort of towards the end did a little but
I I sort of feel like I what I really
wish was happening now is and I don't
really care about the abstergo stuff
with with four and and and going on like
yeah I don't I don't really care about
like uh that kind of stuff like the the
way they handled it after that so oh
we're
going forget me
so
[Music]
my name is Fran P I'm executive director
for the studio and Senior producer on
the new project I was one of the first
one to start in uoft Montreal I believe
that I was number
56 since 97 to now at the company
Chang we all matured we all made a lot
of
mistakes uh tried different things had a
lot of success on stuff Less on others
but we've all
learned that's been the beauty of
Ubisoft in Quebec in Montreal is that
company that gives you the chance to try
stuff and to create because when you do
something for the first time you
[Music]
inovate so these are actually uh quite
old memories you know uh it's few pages
you know of design research I've
saved I remember the first time seeing
ac1 uh it was mind-blowing it was I've
never
seen you know a character touching the
world in such a unique way I've never
seen a world that was so detailed and so
rich we had no engine uh so we built our
own engine from scratch um and all we
had to go on was our taste as you can
imagine when you don't have any specs
you're basically given a blank check you
can invent the world if you want and we
completely did invent the world like the
amount of features that we had the final
game had nine missions the the original
game that we designed had
72 Assassin's Creed is about
transporting people to a time that they
can never really truly
visit the games have always had this
really great sense of freedom of
exploring somewhere of going to a
historical context in these amazing
looking worlds I don't want the player
just to focus focus on fight and action
and look at the ground you know I want
people to look up it's an open world so
I want the people to wait for the for
the sunrise we saw this little prototype
of Naval Combat that they were doing for
AC3 we got super excited cuz it was
beautiful it looked fun and and I think
this was the thing that kind of kicked
off the idea that what if Assassin's
Creed went into the Golden Age of
piracy for every game we try to to bring
new colors new vibrant
flavors Brotherhood was really the
sequel of AO I mean people love so much
a in ac2 that it was really good to see
him again and to see how grown he was he
was a leader now not this young men
anymore we wanted to be able to climb
everywhere to discover every places but
have like no limitation on the
exploration being able to just do cool
things with parkour me I can't do that I
can't climb buildings and jump over
rooftops with this hisory we really
showcase that the franchise can go
anywhere with the frontier the snow
there's actually a full seasonal weather
system so you have uh summer fall winter
and spring we dreamed big and just tried
stuff and then at some point it was
working and it was
magical I was a kid and not very happy
at school I was always drawing always
dreaming drawing like castles places I'm
still doing the same thing you know now
it's it's like creating Universe
creating worlds and this is what I love
to do I sat at home playing ac2 in my
living room and set out loud to my
husband oh my God this game I just love
this game so much I'd love to work on
this this is so cool then when you get
the opportunity to work on that game you
feel very connected to it you feel
protective of it it's like a child you
want it to do really well innovating in
AC is always both exciting you know and
tricky Innovation isn't necessarily like
going crazy it's about like finding the
difference that matters and also keeping
the soul of the brand
alive I always say it's really hard to
just say okay let's innovate let's start
innovating there's no such thing uh
instead you know I can say that raising
as many lightning rods as possible
hopefully lightning will
strike every year we take risks this one
we may have take too too many risks
um there were a lot of ambitious
elements it was the biggest city we'd
ever built it was a really complex City
and if you look at it it looks beautiful
everything was fresh everything was new
it was this huge ambition which was
which was amazing ACU was the first one
in the AC brand where we saw that it was
a much lower Metacritic for people to
work so hard on something for 4 years
and then to have the reception that it
had you're leaving a piece of yourself
that thing it's like your your kid being
told you're ugly and you're fat and that
it hurts your little heartbreaks a
little bit the worth thing that can
happen actually uh when you release a
game is to have one of your
bug uh becoming the front cover of the
entire internet nobody's happy when four
uh years of hard work are just image you
know with the BG some people took it
personally some people took it upon
themselves that you know they they they
made mistakes at the same time I do feel
for the fans who felt somehow that it
didn't meet their expectations uh that's
disappointing as well and uh that's uh
something we can never um uh take for
granted as a developer but the main
thing for me is you look at that
critically you do post-mortems and you
say what can we
improve Ubisoft is is very aware that as
we push the games out we constantly need
to innovate and bring something new and
I've got this great core of Technology
that's there um but how can we do even
more with it by listening to the
comments reading the forums reading the
the reviews we always base our next
steps on that so we really took a step
back we had to admit you know the the
the flaws for sure there's always
challenges um but to me when you have a
challenge you you face it and you move
forward and then you pick yourself up
and you move on to the next challenge
that you have and you build on the
things you did well and the things that
people enjoyed and that they wanted more
of in the end what is at the core of our
work is really to think about the player
so this is these people we should never
ever forget the players are our audience
but we are also players we want the game
to be the best possible player
experience because we all play our games
right here right now we're in the middle
of production of a new Assassin's Creed
game um there's hundreds of people
working on the project and we're working
on making sure we do an amazing
we want to do something that doesn't
exist we don't know how we will make it
we worked hard we fail we retry we test
Etc and in the end we do something that
we hope people will like we're putting a
lot of new features new things that the
player hasn't been able to do before in
the game I really like to have people to
think in a few years 5 years 6 years is
you remember that game that we did in
2015 it was great from missions to
features to cinemattic IC to story every
second of this experience it's going to
be
amazing
London
1868 the center of the industrialized
World profits see progress while workers
never sleep slavery not only comes
through irons and chains but through our
very struggle to
survive time for a
change enough of those who seek only
their own
gain we're amidst an industrial
revolution the telegraph electricity are
changing the way that we live shap ing
our
future but it must be a future for
everyone a different Revolution is
rising more
subtle a blaze From the Ashes of an old
Brotherhood we shall
rise street gangs will be our
armies the slums our
[Music]
Fortress they say this is the modern
era I say it's time for a
rebirth and we shall lead the
way my name is mot and I'm I'm a
creative director at Ubisoft Quebec City
Assassin's Creed Syndicate takes place
in London in
1868 the Industrial Revolution in
essence is society going from almost a
medieval Society to the modern society
in which we live in today it's an
increase in productivity that's never
been seen before in the history of
mankind you see Transportation breaking
through in the span of a few years
enough railroads were constructed to go
around the circumference of the earth
it's a world that's ruled by science
we'll see tons of progress in medicine
that prongs the lifetime of people from
about 20 years old to 50 years
old it's a world that's no longer ruled
by Kings or by religion it's a world
that's ruled by money and this is
something that completely changes
Society you have the upper classes which
still rule the city because they are are
the ones who have the right to vote so
the faith of the lower classes was
pretty much to either work hard and to
Die Young or to resort to something new
the industrial era sees the birth of
organized crime a bit as we know it
today it's really a concept that takes
root in the Victorian era people would
bend together to try to defend their
common interest in what we could call
syndicates
so the new Assassin of Assassin's Creed
Syndicate his name is Jacob fry Jacob is
a born and raised assassin he's going to
have allies that are the street gangs of
London Eevee is twin sister of Jacob
she's the more calculated the more
rational a personality she's the one
that's going to guide uh Jacob through
his quest to free up London Jacob will
always approach situation with a really
Hands-On and head-on approach so he will
be more rash more brutal more
confrontational he's all about the trill
he's all about the
[Music]
chase
need
Assassin's Creed Syndicate will be the
fastest paced Assassin's Creed that
we've ever built the speed of combat in
Assassin's Creed Syndicate has changed
from the past we are making combat much
more closer range than ever in the past
the reason we're doing this is that the
Victorian era has changed the way we
think about weapons you can no longer
walk down the streets with a a sword at
your hip you would be arrested people
fought with hidden knives hidden blades
uh with brass knuckles so there's a lot
of freedom for the player to create
chaos we are making combat much more
like a brawl in which you have to
control uh the crowd and jump from one
enemy to another enemy one of the key
Innovations of Assassin's Creed
Syndicate is its traffic system and it's
going to open up so many more gameplay
possibilities players can jump on top of
vehicles they can drive them they can
integrate them to parkour they can kill
and assassinate people from Vehicles it
makes the combat much more faster paced
but also more bruthal and more lethal
than ever
before let me show you what I mean in
this first gameplay walkthrough of
Assassin's Creed
Syndicate it's Reckless it's clever the
blighters control every criminal
Enterprise in the city if they worked
for us yes but they work for the
Templars now they paid off by the
Templars slight difference if we take
control of the gangs we take control of
London from the bottom up you are
talking about building yourself an army
Miss fry tell him this is complete
Madness you need to consolidate your
control I can keep the rival gangs and
the police from sweeping in and seizing
the territory you can't very well send
bloody Norah an engraved invitation we
have no idea where they hold up yeah we
do you found them the batties are
operating out of the rery blood nor will
be there good work claraa tremendous
work Jacob can't talk now Henry duty
calls to your
health apologies Mr
Green we are now in the city of London
one of the seven Burrows that you'll
experience in Assassin's Creed Syndicate
the city of London was the economic and
financial heart of London in the 19th
century the burrow fully embodies the
usel and bustle Spirit associated with
Victorian London booming businesses busy
sidewalks and even busier
streets new to our game are iconic modes
of transportation including trains and
carriages only presentes in Victorian
London carriages will change how you
play Assassin's Creed you can take the
rains and Traverse the City faster than
ever before you can also hide in them
adding another tool to your stealth game
or run over targets and enemies the
possibilities are
endless in this Mission Jacob wants to
take over one of the Templars control
gangs in order to build an Army against
the Templars that run the city to do so
he will need to conquer the burrow by
dislodging the enemy gang from their
stronghold not unlike big cities today
rich and poor share the same environment
even the richest neighborhood like
Westminster had areas where the police
would not dare set foot these slums were
where street gangs ruled with the simple
push of a button we'll activate stealth
mode as we are entering enemy controlled
territory also new to our game the Rope
launcher will change the way you
navigate throughout the city with this
new tool you can climb the highest
building in seconds or a zipline from
rooftop to
Rooftop
let's trigger eagal Vision to study our
[Music]
surroundings
we can see that one of our allies is in
trouble let's give him a hand we first
need to eliminate the lookout to make
sure he doesn't call reinforcements the
throwing knives will take him out
silently well that doesn't look entirely
[Music]
honest
we are facing a lot of enemies so the at
first approach is probably not a good
idea also new to our game is the ability
to use the environment to take out your
enemies
another one of our allies is in trouble
let's take care of this before it's too
late for
him are you in danger don't theight
disreputable please don't start any
trouble now that our Ally is free thanks
for the we'll ask him to assist us in
our fight for this slum here is the
stronghold leader highlighted in yellow
let's try to take him out with stealth
as he is more dangerous than common tugs
we'll use the
[Music]
[Applause]
yeah
[Music]
this slum is now one and your gang
occupies the
territory well well the Assassins have
come crawling out of their OES have
they damn it boys deal with this come
back here
you we were caught in a trap
orchestrated by Bloody Norah one of the
seven Templar gang leaders her rule of
the burrow has been one of Cruelty and
suffering we need to take her out once
and for
all let's go
up
go
bloody no's thugs are trying to make
sure you don't get raming our Carriage
to kill our Carriage has taken some
damage but seems to be holding
[Music]
up
[Applause]
we made it to the gang and all out
confrontation between your gang and your
rival for the ultimate control of the
Bor Jacob feels right at home in these
fights thanks to our new fighting system
as it is faster and more responsive than
ever
before
[Music]
ladies and
gentlemen we are Jacob and eie
Fry and as of this
moment you all work for
[Music]
us
the team is really focused and working
really hard for the last two years and
making sure that we have an amazing and
fallish single player
experience all the people I encounter on
the teams I keep asking to take good
care in like the little Street Corner
that they are working on to try to tell
a story with all the tools that they
have with the crowd that they are
placing so that the the game has a story
to tell everywhere the player turns a
stone
it's an intimate relationship between
the player and the protagonist as he
relives his life in a pivotal moment in
history it's a completely new kind of
Assassin's Creed that it's respectful of
the franchise but that it transforms its
gameplay in a way that makes it more fun
than ever I want them to feel like it's
the best Assassin's Creed that's ever
been
made
it's a bloody marvelous time to be alive
an age of
invention so many clever Blok streaming
up impossible machines sorting away more
gold than Queen Victoria
herself but none of those Shillings ever
makes it into the pockets of the poor
Devils whose blood is spilled building
this glorious Empire the working class
sleep walks through life unaware of the
machine that drives
them let's wake them up then shall
[Applause]
weom but
I'm I'm pushing till I
it I leave
it
[Music]
dreams
[Applause]
holy [__] okay that looked awesome what
you K looks pretty good can I say I'm
going to start because because it's me
I'm going to say something negative to
start and then I and then and then I
want you to talk yeah can I just say for
the next for the next thing that you
show you be soft do turn down the damn
Bloom on the thing because jeez the all
I saw in the game was half of everything
just looked completely washed out from
from whiteness so come on get a grip
otherwise lighting now now now now
moving to the positive elements is Alexa
yes so I actually I saw Syndicate last
week I went to Quebec City and got a
chance to see it in the studio and meet
the people making it and um I'm I'm
really optimistic I really like what I
saw I'm one of the big things that I
really like and I think people will
really like and they showed it in the
gameplay demo is those Vehicles you can
hijack vehicles like GTA style punch
people out take their horse and carriage
and like run over people in the streets
I really like it and if you notice the
people on the sidewalks will react like
if you run them over they'll fall down
and people will be like oh [__] and
they'll like move away I was suddenly
watching this thinking oh it's GTA
Assassin's Creed it looks really good I
I think this is going to be I can't wait
for like the YouTube let's play videos
of people like flipping carriages and
crashing them you can crash carriages to
cause diversions um the developers also
told me there will be trains and boats
in some capacity you actually see
concept art in their developer Diary of
uh Jacob fighting on a train which is a
moving train which is super cool um I
saw the I saw Jacob uh fighting on top
of these carriages I saw him jumping uh
at one point I jumped on top of or the
demo I was watching in Quebec the guy
jumped on the back of a carriage and a
police officer jumped up after me and
like threw me off it was or me I me I
wasn't playing threw the driver off it
was super I'm really excited can you
tell I'm like a little you're very
excited I'm a little like watching that
it makes it makes the The Carriage uh
Chase actually looked pretty interesting
it wouldn't be the first Carriage Chase
in Assassin's Creed this has appeared
before and actually um previous Carriage
chases haven't been the strongest suit
of other Assassin's Creed games but what
I liked about that is it looked it
looked like you know it it's it's it's
supposed to be a little bit clumsy right
it's it's this big thing with like a you
know the wagon in the back Tipp B and
you know it's courses and stuff so you
can't expect it to be perfectly like you
know Tweaky or whatever I'm making up
words now that's a new word I made up
TWY it looked really fun um I'm more
interested like the combat too I'm kind
of curious like you saw the com I saw
the combat there it looked really
fast-paced um one thing that that I saw
and I don't know how this how
representative this is of the whole but
in the in the in the gang fight we saw
like one gang fight gang fight yes um
but in that in that uh in the bit that
we saw one thing that really intrigued
me was uh the fact that you didn't see
like a horde of dudes surrounding him
and then it becomes like a an ultra
choreographed um thing where everybody's
all waiting around to attack until until
the moment um now I don't know if that's
partially because of the way it's set up
he's only taking on one attacker at a
time because everybody else is busy so
the thing the thing about the gang
fights I did I saw the the gang fights
in like this uh when I went and saw the
game and it uh you run in with your
dudes you run into the gang fight and
not all of them go after you like the
opposing AI the the people on the
opposing gang will go after other people
in your gang like everyone is not
focused on you so it feels like a gang
fight and as Jacob or whoever you're
playing as you can go around and say all
right I'm going to take out this guy I'm
going to stab this one I'm going to stun
this person like you are part of a group
fight it's not a group of people and you
and the group of people are focused on
you while everyone else tries to them
off like it's a true gang fight and I
love the gang fights like that looks
really cool they block off the city
streets you see people cheering on the
sides like it's really cool when you saw
it I mean did when you talk to them did
they mention that that was like a pretty
typical scenario in the game like is
that how a lot of the combat's going to
play out so that it's not like a bunch
of dudes and then everything just
everybody happening to wait until you
know you're you're in a position to
actually you know they counter they
talked about retooling the AI to be more
responsive um re gang fights um gang
fights will be like that and and there's
a gang fight you a gang fight is how you
get control of a burrow like you were in
a gang fight because you had to take out
bloody Norah and take out her game so
her gang so that will be something that
you're doing a lot of the gang fights
will be a lot of them um as far as
combat goes yes and what I saw what I
saw um well we were sort of sneaking
around and taking people out in alleys
and whatnot um people won't won't wait
around for you like the AI doesn't wait
around you they'll pull out their gun
they'll run after you I didn't see any
any AI that I was in combat with
standing still um another thing about
the combat is it's all Close Quarters so
it's all brawling like you're in 1868
London you're in the criminal
underground unless you're doing
something like that where you're where
you're sneaking around but um let's
let's actually talk about this for a
second they changed the stealth um it's
no longer cover-based like you you're
not you're not uh going to be focusing
on blending in with crowds or hiding out
in bushes or or sneaking uh or just
hiding it's not hiding based so it's
basically just a stealth yes yeah it's
stealth it's a more modern stealth like
you'll be crouching you hit a button to
crouch and you sneak around and you just
sort of sort of soft snap into the cover
when you you get close to it and can
when you're crouching yeah and you can
use um like the the throwing knives work
differently now you have hallucinogenic
darts so you can actually throw them
into fire sources and it'll puff out and
it'll make the enemies around that fire
Source um kill each other and as we saw
just here you can use the throwing
knives to knock things down that are
hanging in the sky like they're not just
for killing anymore which is really cool
also the whistles back you can Crouch
around a corner and whistle and someone
will come toward you and you can just
pull them into cover and pull them
behind whatever you wherever you are and
just stab them and what would Assassin's
Creed be without a bail of hay right
look at these kids these kids are like
uh look see look everyone is reacting to
you do you notice this yeah all those
people they're like oh like oh
and the guy's coming around it's like
not going over there see this guy hears
you that a little he's screwed look at
these mustaches A+ on the mustaches and
the facial hair in Syndicate yeah lot
lots of good facial hair I was actually
like I'm kind of glad I was going to
shave this morning and just trim up my
beard and I'm like glad I didn't know
cuz now I'm now I'm kind of bushy
keeping with the game this this woman
didn't stand a chance look at her bye
and she's our Ally hooray she's she get
nice tip of the Hat top of the morning
Governor speak speaking of which you
know I think I I'd love to see about
more of the I mean we don't really know
a whole lot we know about the you know
the characters now and of course I know
you want to talk about Eevee some when
get want talk about eeve um but I I one
thing I'm curious about is like where
the story is going to go and things like
that I mean I think that you you have a
preview going up I do uh 9:30 should be
up now actually um we saw we were told
uh that the story for Assassin's Creed
Syndicate you have uh Eve and Jacob and
Eve and Jacob have been bored born
outside of London and you will be
experiencing London for the first time
along with the twins they're twins um I
really like the dynamic here she's
sitting up he's hunched over I like
their banter you actually there will be
story missions where you can actually
pick who you play as but both of them
will also have story missions specific
to them now Eevee we are told we're
going to get more information on her a
little later this summer she's going to
get her own time to shine in the media
Spotlight um I suppose but right now
they are showing off Jacob so we will
definitely be getting more from her but
I really like her I like the little
freckles on her face I like that they're
a brother and sister something that I
something that I didn't like about Unity
is I think the romance between like the
adopted siblings was I don't know it
took away from the story for me I know
it was sort of the romance was the thing
but I'm kind of tired of romances I
really like the dynamic that you see
between siblings and I'm just so excited
that we're getting a brother and a
sister that's not oh I'm the older
sister and I'm doing whatever or I'm the
older brother and I'm guarding my little
sister they're twins they're the same
age um and I really like the idea of
sort of the idea of sibling rivalry but
also but also working together like I
have two brothers and I love the idea of
like sibling stuff so I'm excited about
this let's point out that the clip that
you just saw was was not them I'm so
sorry them point out that we're that we
didn't just see a hot brother and sister
kiss Al although a brother and sister
kiss would also not be new to Assassin's
Creed if we saw it there that was that
we we've seen a little we've seen a
little incest before on this series that
was Aro and Elise from Unity with the
Smoochy smoochi no but yeah no I'm
really excited uh to finally have a
leading female assassin I think that's
Harrah like that's awes so I got at
least one of my one of my hopes came
true you got it one of your hopes your
fondest wish uh and and I know oh by the
way we you should tune in at 2:00 um 2:
p.m. Pacific time because we have an
episode of the lobby um you'll talk a
lot more about sort of what you saw of
Assassin's Creed Syndicate um you'll be
getting I'm sure you'll be getting more
into uh I almost said a lease which
would have been really
bad Eevee it's another eame it's another
eame I like that name e um and uh of
course I'll pimp myself for just half a
second because I'll also be answering a
bunch of question about The Witcher 3
wild Hunt so tune in for that but also
we saw the you know there was there was
one spot where where she kind of Saved
Jacob is this his name Jacob right okay
okay I'm I'm so eeve fry um but uh you
saw her use the the the Rope or whatever
to like actually the Rope launcher get
the get the revolver out of uh her the
bloody Nora bloody Nora I almost said
Bloody Baron because I've still got
Witcher 3 in my head you're so funny I
love you but uh yeah to what what the
what's up with the the Rope launcher so
the Rope launcher is the new weapon um
Ubisoft seemed the developer seemed
really excited about it and I was like
okay is it like a it's a a thing it's
sort of functions like Batman's
grappling hook in the Arkham games you
can use it to surmount buildings which
we saw he Jacob shot it upwards and he
scaled the building much much quicker
you can in your assassin Gauntlet you
can shoot the husen darts from it um the
interesting thing about the Rope
launcher that I saw when if you are
standing on a roof or anywhere you can
shoot it to another rooftop and you can
zipline if it's lower you can zip line
down if it's higher you can actually
climb it across and that turns you can
attach it anywhere and that rope
launcher makes all of the airspace in
Victorian London available for aerial
assassinations so you could in theory do
this stop halfway through look down and
assassinate the person below you turn
shoot the Rope launcher back up and just
rope launcher right out of there like it
looks super cool rope launcher rope
launcher right on out of there no super
it looks super cool and I like that it
gives you more more attack options I
love Assassin's Creed games and I love
action adventure games with stealth in
it that have the stealth option but I am
like I am a stealth player I tried to
stealth only stealth through the Last of
Us and just failed miserably but I
prefer I don't think you can I mean
Assassin's Creed has never really been
been just stealth stealth game but I
like that this is sort of bringing it
into a more modern stealth approach than
using stealth the way a lot of a lot of
recent games use it and I like that I
have I have that option that I can just
sneak around and I have a lot more
options to do sneaky kills right I'm
great so I got one more question for you
that I have if if you know the answer
which is about this territory control
thing yes um I'm kind of curious about
that because like it brings to mind
something like okay so Assassin's Creed
Revelation had the whole thing where um
I mean not only did you capture capture
places but then you had yeah but then
you had to defend them and then had that
stupid Tower Defense uh mini game built
in there so we'll forget about the Tower
Defense mini game for a minute um but uh
I'm I'm kind of curious are you going to
have to then defend that are they are
you know do you know if they're if uh
the gangs are going to try to come in
and you know take control of uh the the
regions that you've already taken for
your own is there like a tug of war so I
know that like your goal as Jacob and
Eevee is to Temp the Templars control
the underbelly of London as well as the
not underbelly of London but each burrow
will have a gang leader that you have to
overthrow and you have to capture their
strongholds and like get their men and
bring them to you like we saw in the
demo we are Jacob fry you work for us
now like okay like this is them burning
the just like oh okay sure yeah and
they're like of course the name of their
group by the way is the Rooks that's the
name of their it they're the Rooks um
and you kidnap these Burrows and they're
yours there are seven buroughs in London
and you have to get all of the
strongholds I don't actually know if you
if you then have to defend them I I'd
like to know it would be something
interesting to know for certain I also
like the fact that it's the Rooks so for
people that don't know there in in Far
Cry 3 there's actually an island called
Rook Island and if you go to Rook Island
in Far Cry 3 there's Assassin's Creed
Easter eggs on that island so it's not
actual Easter eggs it's not like you
know right it's not like you're going
and hunting you know for actual egg I
can't believe I'm I'm I can't believe
I'm explaining myself I'm still tired is
it I have have a little bit more of my
sip of stuff here so yeah that was uh
Assassin's Creed Syndicate uh former
codenamed Victory uh you can look at my
previews they're all up on spot.com
right now I'll be talking more about it
on the lobby and thank you for watching
thank you my
pleasure